you know there were a lot of things over
the weekend that made us scratch our
heads but none more so than the fact
that Kanye West announced that he is
running for president it feels like a
publicity stunt but here's what you need
to know about Kanye's campaign decided
in 2020 to run for president Kanye is
100% running for president that's what a
source tells et adding Kim is always
unwavering in her support and loves that
he isn't afraid of what people think
about him but for the most part
Hollywood isn't having it actress
Octavia Spencer tweeted too much
foolishness today
hashtag sit all the way down Tiffany
Haddish joke I too am running for
president of the United States John
Stamos posted this campaign pic as VP
for his former full house co-star joking
and if anything should happen to Saget
and this meme was our favorite Keeping
Up with the Kardashians White House
edition so is Kanye for real or is this
a publicity stunt he did just drop new
music then walk i8b Kanye well our
source claims the White House dream is
legit and it's the same way when he
launched his fashion brand he was
obsessed but we're told there are others
who are close to Kanye who think he's
being impractical and is just caught up
in the moment
in fact apparently Kanye has no campaign
organization hasn't found any paperwork
and has missed the ballot deadline in
several key states
[Music]